ja wir kommen zu einem preis will ihr
können testen war hier einfach ein
bisschen unsere technik optimieren um
möglichst gute bedingungen zu schaffen
für das anstehende seminar im
sommersemester 2009 10 zum thema
philosophie der digitalität ich möchte
jetzt einfach hier so ein bisschen
während der live stream zu langsam aber
sicher und land geben sollte möchte ich
einfach ein bisschen was erzählen
zu den aktuellen planungen die die
seminar betreffen
ganz wichtig ist mir dass wir hier
kommentarfunktion haben
es wird hier neben kommentar funktion
geben rechten hand und da hat schon
eingeschrieben guten tag tolle idee ich
schreibe zurück ok wird nämlich mit
interagieren
ein logo ist dieses würde mit dieser
beute das heißt ich habe hier tablett in
der hand und ich werden uns zu wehren
ich dann dieses seminar ergebe
kommentaren anschauen und dann begegnete
als wenn die lage auftaucht einfach auch
dazu was sagt wir müssen noch ein
bisschen optimieren wir es gibt immer
die frage ob dir der ton gut ist
entsprechend richtung dieses
richtmikrofon fertiggestellt haben
wir haben jetzt eigentlich ziemlich gute
verbindung über das local area network
und ich weiß angeboten werden eigentlich
die beste verfügbar werden dann
verbindung es denn sein dass uns youtube
noch ein bisschen probleme bereitet
faszinierend video qualität anbelangt
aber wir wollen
und wir haben schon öfters zuschauer das
ist also ganz erfreulich haben schon ein
like tests durchführen müssen
und die zuschauer dieses videos sind
herzlich eingeladen
im kommentarbereich ein paar anregungen
noch ein zu geben wie sie sich das
vorstellen und wünsche haben wir wollen
jedenfalls mit zum ersten mal überhaupt
ein seminar live streamen und wir wollen
wirklich möglichst maximal interagieren
dass die zuschauer geben hier zählen
aber auch zu hause ihre fragen eingehen
können und verliert dann einfach so ein
möglichst authentisches digitale
seminaren das nicht über die vitalität
rede zumal selbst vitalität macht das
soll es auch für heute gewesen sei
dann schon besser sind als der letzte
test ich sage ich tschüss und bis zu
einem nächsten